Harold you've been a criticism of the
critic of this plan
the FCC just adopted it what's gonna go
wrong now well it's a sad day for the
American public and for the Internet
globally here we have for the first time
the United States after the past 20
years priding itself on not regulating
the internet suddenly something has
changed and the American government has
decided to regulate the Internet this
cannot be good for the American public
yet those who are advocate title to say
that something has changed and that the
Internet service providers have started
to charge fees to pick favors to pick
winners over losers on the content side
is is are you saying the tail to is the
wrong way to do it or that any
regulation of the Internet is bad I
would actually don't believe there's any
need for regulation and all of these
allegations about ISPs imposing charges
on service for on content companies is
really this is all hypothetical it's not
they can't point to actual examples this
is all regulation in the name of what
might possibly happen in the future it's
not addressing actual problems that we
have today it's not addressing actual
complaints that are before the FCC
well let me respectfully disagree I mean
Netflix is a company that has been
compelled to pay to get ahead of the
line and there's a company that opposes
having to make those kind of payments
let me read a statement from from Reed
Hastings the CEO of Netflix and what he
had to say about this specifically he
said strong net neutrality prevents ISPs
from charging a toll for interconnection
to services like Netflix they must
provide significant access to their
network without charge this is a company
that he goes on to say allowing fast
lanes gives ISPs a perverse incentive to
boost revenues by allowing their
networks to congestion the power to pick
winners and losers on the Internet
so what do you say this is a company
that has been compelled to pay this to
Comcast to Verizon to get ahead of the
line I respectfully disagree I'm afraid
that what we're seeing here has just
been from
flix Netflix entered into agreements for
contracts with Verizon and Comcast to
effectively put themselves at the head
of the line in front of millions of
other content providers and users on the
internet before Netflix entered into
that agreement it was treated the same
as everybody else well that's exactly
what title 2 is going to require its it
quite likely will prohibit the type of
contract that Netflix entered into well
they don't want to have that's their
argument
for I mean furthermore you know what
they say is that it let the the ISPs
congest their networks or make their
networks look at congested so they could
charge that fee and that that was a sort
of a perverse problem what do you do
about that problem creating an incentive
for the last mile deliverers of content
to create that congestion for the
benefit of more income first of all I
don't agree that there is a problem I
think a lot of this is really a
manufactured problem but I think more to
the point let's say let's hypothetically
say there is a problem is the solution
to impose telephone regulation on every
broadband provider in America is that
really the path we want to go down is
the solution to congestion problems to
make every ISP in America look exactly
like the telephone company I don't think
so I think this is the wrong solution
for a wrong problem and a problem that
likely doesn't exist yet it's all
hypothetical hypothetically but not
hypothetical a Twitter another company
that hasn't had to pay these kinds of
fees but I was also come up strongly
against it I want to read a statement
from Twitter and see if I get your
reaction
Twitter telling us quote we are in a
blog post on their site said we strongly
support ensuring that such net
neutrality rules include prohibitions
against blocking or throttling of sites
and services as well as paid
prioritization of some traffic over
others I feel like you know the the the
the companies in Silicon Valley not all
of them but many of them are maybe
arguably most of them have have see real
problems in this for the development of
the services they've already created in
the future services they may develop a
going forward first of all again Twitter
doesn't point to an example of a single
website that is being blocked by ISPs in
the past 20 years the FCC has have
complaints about one site being blocked
and the FCC took decisive action to
unblock that it didn't require new title
2 regulations in order to do that what
is going on in fact though is that these
new regulations will enable companies to
march into court and to ask the FCC to
impose all kinds of conditions on on
ISPs
I don't think this is a very good
solution I think this is a solution
that's going to lead to dispute
resolutions going on in courts for the
past 20 years these same companies that
America is the leading country in the
world in terms of the development of new
Internet companies they've operated
extremely well without the government
looking over their shoulder deciding
every single thing that they can and
cannot do it really baffles the mind to
think that these companies think they're
going to do better in a world in which
the federal government is going to be
reviewing every decision they make